the technicals his compound angle
formulas like soy formulas right and I'm
right posed to that idea I will call
that thank you
okay but a better thing to clear the
halassi we are in fact not expressly or
equations by identities okay so what I'm
going to show you is a bunch of things
that are not just equal to each other
sometimes sign of this is equal to sign
the cause of this sometimes the way I'm
going to show you ones that are equal
all that time for all values of whatever
angles you put in close this has a we
have what we're gonna do is you're going
to learn six of these identities today
okay so we've learned a whole bunch of
my thirties today and this means sort of
to do the six put one by geometry so you
can have to do a triangle with me make
it make it fairly large makeup image
once we prove the first one by geometry
the other five will follow using the
other identities we already know in
cases just one that's critical and then
last sort of superficial it does have to
be a running sorry is writing with here
in the corner and then you're going to
add it within this triangle and so
another Troisi such that such that i
let's put some wave and I get X what my
corners let's get three let's get away
I was so what we going to do is we're
going to okay who eat or why just
perpendicular to a beam size inside is
its side space like this which is a half
right like so but I will call that P
kids knuckle thank you sign 10 plus 3
and then 1 lastly we're going to join
Arlington be okay by the way so what
we're gonna try and do here is we have
to find some angles and some science
right and what we're looking for is a
simple way to express because this has
an obvious wrong outside okay when we do
something like but that's not the same
we don't race where this is going
calculus hey like what K we have any
status the underworld the repot enable
this is getting distributive law right
of bills three pieces is this five I'm
gonna kind of very client that gets
distributed to the 10 and to the a so
you get 15 plus 5 now if we have to do
the same thing with trig right you might
say ok what about sine of two different
engine okay now a superficial look at
these are big okay we'll be doing sine
of both of these so what I decided
- add the other can right so you might
compare it's still inside
so just quickly evaluate Ivan sighs it's
me but we made don't forget to close
write and sign 20 is an argument that
comes from the graph can I get a couple
of decimal places
let's get three let's get three zero
point five one six three DP okay what
you come which which is troubling is
troubling because we know what sign was
20 is its sign 30 which is a heart in
the pod but it's not to say ten but I
like this one is not equal to scientific
all this it's not and I having other
angles how do I actually get me to get
something meaningful
okay now by the way just before I launch
into this nice good these are the kinds
of places we will stop now okay cuz I
can do every symbol which I got bring up
two pieces which I know exactly how you
make it
a Ladykiller length then we'll make more
than 45 and 30 dr. K and then I can get
some stuff out of this is using these
identities I'm about to show you gonna
make that's not at the main point the
main place where this is going is
calculus you're like what
we haven't even we haven't looked at
that we haven't touched it we haven't
read thought at all we're getting there
okay we try to build the pieces right
what you're getting we're gonna cut
everybody to hell because the
foundations we have alpha beta which are
arbitrary angles I can change the size I
wanna give you two minutes to work out
what is the size of every other angle in
this patient that means you're a spy and
they just tries mission obviously varies
so that's 10 minutes just to give it a
go okay now in this case right I haven't
broken not anyone off from being a hair
into two different pieces it's still be
one take you to the shop okay and it's
just that 210 is equal to 180 plus study
okay but the arguments mean we made for
why this is therefore I'm moving to this
is an argument that comes from the graph
right it's because tan is periodic then
we every 180 degrees it's gonna repeat
and repeat so that's why that's equal so
what you come up with this kind of like
a coincidence right like I can I can um
you know I can come up with kinases
where it's like oh it'll work but that
doesn't mean it always works okay in
fact it always never does alright so
we're gonna use this triangle I could
draw through hundreds of triangles in
fact this there's hundreds of proofs for
what this is equal to okay but I like
this one because it's relatively simple
I call this a and I've called that
because I'm gonna put some angle on here
alpha and beta I'll match some alpha
with the a and I think it's here with
the B let me just double-check I put in
my place
yes good okay now I've got alpha here
baby here I ain't one link because I can
do everything I'm about to do without
knowing what any of these lengths are
but if I make it a particular length
then it'll make all of the maths easier
it doesn't compromise the person I'm
just gonna make this length you if you
order the simplest I'm gonna make it one
unit actually yeah you're fighting same
question you know funny sides okay you
should get exactly the same thing as
Infernus so
what do we got here look at that we have
alpha beta which are two mobs a tray and
you change the size I'm going to give
you two minutes now to work out what is
the size of every other angle in this
picture there aren't that many right and
they just trying who she can use like
some of the triangle angles on a street
like citron
I'll give you two minutes just to work
out what they are there aren't that me
give it a go okay that sounds like
security monsters sounds like the sound
take you longer answer I can we'll start
with the easy ones a PQ size 90 degrees
thank you it's not a straight line same
triangle a QP size 19 minus alpha I
should say 90 degrees minus alpha but
you know what I mean okay next angle how
about how about bqp and that leaves us
with escape here which by angle some
straight line is alpha plus beta let me
see oh there's this one up here
depending on the way you ride it with
your brackets or not yeah I'm just gonna
I'll write it without ya okay so we'll
need almost all of these angles almost
okay now I want to transition from
angles to sides because that's what the
trig ratios are about right
relating sides and angles together so
I'm going to look into these four
triangles because they're all the right
angle and I'm gonna look at the angles
in them and what they can tell me okay
so for instance have a look at this one
in the middle bpq you can see that right
now I've got one as this side over here
that's the that's the hypotenuse isn't
it okay so in that triangle middle
triangle what is cos 3 da equal to cos
beta adjacent on hypotenuse adjacent
over hypotenuse right so it's BP on one
do you agree with that so I'm just gonna
write that as B P yep speak it so this
is kind of funny I was looking to get a
ratio but because and you see why I made
this one right now I find that this side
is just equal to cos beta I mean that
sides equal to cos beta so I'm gonna
write that in BP it's over here cause
speed up okay so far so good
okay what else can you see in that same
triangle what else do you see in that
triangle I can do the other side can't I
it's the opposite all happen is I'm
gonna use sine right so I'll say sine
theta equals PQ on one which is just PQ
okay so I have cos beat her up in the
top now I've sign me up
it's kind of handy all right what other
things can I see let's go to this next
triangle in the corner so I'm over here
bcq misuk you can see that the angular
most interested in is this one down here
right because it's going to get me to I
grabbed it off it's going to get me to
sign of alpha plus beta right now this
also has I hypotenuse that's equal to
one okay sir a mirror right at sine of
alpha plus beta
what's it equal to which two sides of my
comparing BC on BQ which is what so
that's just be see you care with that
okay we're almost there we almost have
all the pieces okay now I'm gonna have a
look at this triangle over here it's a
bit more messy than the rest because we
don't have the same amount of
information about this triangle that we
do about the others because there's no
hypotenuse of one in this triangle in
fact I don't know what the hypotenuse is
equal to it's not very useful okay yep
okay I can write it in wherever I want
but I can't write it everywhere right
because if I make one here I don't know
there are other isosceles triangles
happening here right it's an the angles
of arbitrary size right so if this is
one I don't know anything else about the
other science right but I can make one
of them one and then any other triangle
where it's two or three or four will
just be similar to this triangle okay
all right so I'm gonna look in this
triangle here a peak okay now what I'm
particularly after is a relationship
between this side and this side over
here a P and P Q so what ratios should I
invoke if I want to relate a P and P Q I
should go 10 right because I got alpha
over here so we opposite or adjacent you
happy with that so all right alpha
equals opposite which is sine beta over
adjacent which is AP and if I don't know
what ap is right that's the whole point
of me doing this okay so now from that
equation there I can swap these two I
can swap them around I'll get an AP
equals sine beta now I can write this a
couple of different ways I could write
this as like when I take it over the
other side it's gonna become caught
right but for reasons that become clear
in about two minutes it's not all that
much of a benefit to write it as clots
I'm just gonna write it as divided by
ten okay now keep in mind these are two
different angles this is no canceling
that can happen here like once beta once
after they have nothing to do with each
other as far as I know what else okay so
actually gonna stay in that way they are
gonna remain a dream I'm just gonna put
that link there ap over here so I've got
sine beta okay
I always there now we're gonna look at
the big triangle that you wrote in the
beginning
okay the big triangle here I've got
alpha yeah I've got 90 minus alpha over
here right can you see that landing
minus alpha because the Peters - bit of
kids on holiday but being that I've got
this side and this side right I'm going
to go down to this angel over here
rather than add in any other identities
I'm just gonna say sine alpha sine alpha
okay what's it equal to in that big
triangle okay
and now you can start to see some of the
benefits of how you just say what
triangle I mean because opposite and
hypotenuse mean completely different
things in different ranges
okay so hold on sine is opposite on
upland effect so opposite over here on
hypotenuse right so I'm gonna have sine
of alpha plus beta right / now this is
going to be kind of big because I have
the hypotenuse in two pieces can you see
that I got one piece here and the other
piece that though what the whole thing
with the whole hypotenuse so I've got a
close excuse me a cos beta there plus
sine beat up on tan alpha okay now this
looks like a mess but it is so very
close to what we want all I want is to
make this subject see that that's what
I'm after
so I'll just I'll just take this
gross-looking denominator and multiply
it over at the same time to stuff that
begin I'm going to switch sides okay so
I have this on the left-hand side are
you ready I'll have sine alpha plus beta
over here right I can't step through
this with me this times this not much
you can do with that can you sine alpha
cos beta okay all right so far so good
now what happens when you multiply this
by this guy mmm
okay now just to make it really clear
I'm gonna write it down okay um I'm
gonna sine alpha sine beta that's that's
all fine right and then I need to divide
by ten alpha what is ten it's sign on
cause isn't it yep
so so I can multiply by flipping it
right I don't really need to do that I'm
just gonna cancel those guys right and
then this will become x cos alpha sine
alpha cos beta plus we tend to write
them in order of the angles cos alpha
sine beta and that not there just to
emphasize it right these two sides of
the equation whatever
Alfre BT you have these are always equal
to each other whatever values there no
yeah that's right okay just like a
congruent statements like these are
exactly the same exactly the same in
every regard it's just another way of
writing the same thing so this guy here
isn't it beautiful has a sort of nice
kind of symmetry to it
sian enough clothes made of Akers sine
alpha cos beta plus cos alpha sine beat
up and like I said we do tend to put it
in order of angles you can write them in
any order you like but I'm going to
highly encourage you to always write it
in the same order whatever order you end
up using and it's probably easiest if
you use the same order behind you so you
don't muddled up what you've got okay as
you'll see in a second this is number
one out of six right when we learned two
three four five and six right
particularly the next three when you
first look at the build fiendishly
similar and it's very easy to confuse
them with each other so do yourself a
favor and write them write the
identities out one way and only one way
that make sense